why did you decide to return to the
character after all this time well he
never really went away
to be honest you know my version
finished in 2003 but then I was exactly
on the American version and the other
remakes you know there wasn't a day went
by when I didn't sort of somehow manage
the escape of David Brent in the office
where you know um
McKenzie crooks on the one show can they
have a clip yes you know quiz machines
use little you know and then it was the
ten year anniversary and the BBC did a
special box set and they put the
episodes onto iPlayer and I did some
intros and I watched them again a bit to
them for the first time and I laughed I
didn't remember some bits you know and I
did a little thing for comic relief that
year and I got sort of hooked again and
it was some just you know a six minute
sketch what David rent was doing now and
he was managing a young rapper in Slough
he's thought it was the Simon Cowell of
the area and then he worms his way into
doing his own song Equality Street which
was an ad-lib in Episode four series one
of the office where I just said we got
on a political wedding song called
equality Street and I thought it'd be
fun to write that and so I had a few
songs because I wrote a few songs with
you original I'd built up a little back
catalogue and I thought I'd do some gigs
and I still haven't thought of doing the
film yet but then while doing the gigs I
that the band which was Andy burrows
from razor lights own band and they were
the musicians and I thought why would
David Brent have this amazing band how
would he do it he's paying for them
their session musicians he's paying to
be famous now and that was the seed of
the idea and now that course he would be
he would be on the last shot of how
everyone wants to be famous now since
the office we have an x-factor Britain's
Got Talent
we've had people get on the apprentice
saying I would destroy anyone that
stands in my way there's a new there's a
new hunger for phone there's a it's
insatiable now you know and people do
anything to be famous now and there's no
difference between feynman in for me
these days people do anything to get on
the telly good or bad and
rewarded for it in their eyes you know
and so it was about that it was about
Brent this old fossil and bring a new
game a different type of Fame and he
sort of up his League and you allude to
that throughout the course of the film
you know that he had that kind of infamy
of being this can a character and yeah
and the documentary series yeah he
thinks this is sort of like Scorsese
following the Rolling Stones round but
it's more of a where are they now type
thing and people don't really remember
him and that you know he goes on the
radio they vote now you're in this you
know a donkey so called the office and I
don't remember you and it's sort of
really insulting these and he's a ghost
and he just can't compete in this new
world of people that do anything to be
famous you know because he's got a
little bit more dignity in a way he saw
much like the underdog now your
sympathies are more within your pet I
think people will identify with this
brand relative to the rest of the world
more than they did with the old brain
where it was the other people that were
sort of normal and he was an idiot but
now he's sort of alright
compared to you know that the alpha
males of this world I confess that when
I heard that there were going to be
songs in it I thought that they were
going to be terrible songs I thought
that musically they were going to be the
negative bankrupting but actually the
songs are really good and they're to
your experience in a music industry as
well doesn't matter well I use all my
any skills I have as a songwriter to try
and you know make them as good as
possible but they have to sort of be
good bad you know that the joke isn't
their comedy songs they're not they're
not comedy songs like Monty Python songs
and there are fictional characters best
attempt at being credible
he just gets things slightly wrong you
know a song like free their free way so
cracking tune but it's a song about
crossing America picking up chicks and
when you realize it's being sung by a 55
year old tampon rep who's never done
that and you know it's is the back story
that's funny
but the album is standalone you know
it's pretty good and again Slough
beautiful tune but it's singing about
Slough no offense
nothing wrong with Slough but that's not
very rock and roll you know yeah
so it's more that he gets bogged down in
in admin you just sent is that the the
title track live on the road again crack
could be a nice a song but he's singing
about rapping now anything that's really
cool and glamorous you know you know he
he's writing about his life um listen
that's sort of quite sweet and honest
and naive still about Brent even though
he's 55 now he's still a bit of a
man-child and that was always the theme
in fact in all my stuff you know men as
boys and women as adults because it's
sort of true and it's sort of funny and
you know men do like to be the center of
attention and he's the epitome of that
except that now as I say there's a new
breed you know you see that people are
going to Celebrity Big Brother they've
gotten they've got no further way to do
anything they can't lose their dignity
they didn't have any you know rent sort
of wants to be respected as well and
they know they don't care about that I
go no I'm the girl I'm gonna get a deal
I'm going to get this I'm gonna get that
I'm going to live my life like an open
wound and I'm gonna make money and I
don't care you know well let's explore
that a little bit more because I really
thought it was noticeable that you know
in the original series he did seem to be
more tolerated by his co-workers he was
a boss obviously but now he's at another
company he's clearly not the boss and
that's been quite badly bullied and I
thought that I was seeing a commentary
on on what has happened to to perhaps
British culture well it's true people
are more ruthless now they're harsher
you know we've got potentially a future
president saying I wanted to punch him
in the face when when did that happen
or even potentially the assassination of
his of his political rival well it's
it's like it's funny a comedian says
something terrible and doesn't mean it
and they get in trouble you know a
potential president says something
terrible and beings it and it may very
mean but she Trump's got more in common
with David Brent than he has JFK he's an
entertainer
he's a reality star you know he's a
billionaire but he wants to be famous so
do you think he's a product of the
culture that we're living through it's
it's
it's sort of fun it eats itself you know
and people are loving it you know people
people want their president to be famous
you know it's it's very strange when the
bun was elected people saying are always
is elitist cuz he had a degree I want my
president to be smarter than me I think
it's quite important you know it's funny
when Trump said I love the uneducated
yeah I know I know you do yeah it's
working and it entered the conversation
during the referendum here as well the
discussion about you know whether
experts were part of the establishment
so should we be listening to them
because the establishment was clearly
behind remain well you know that the
thing is you can't win about democracy
you can't you know that's it if Trump
gets in it's because more people wanted
him in or some people didn't vote or
whatever be you can't win
you know you got to go let's do
something about it let's try and change
their minds that's all you can do is
vocalize and fight and you know and vote
it's it's but isn't part of the problem
that we are vocalizing and fighting
perhaps too much you know if you go on
Twitter that the level of discourse is
it can be pretty brutal well that's a
whole different level now you know it I
don't think it people have changed as
much as everyone's thinks that um you
know they can say what they want now and
they can and it's in a way it's quite
equalizing everyone has their say on
Twitter um but I think that even the
offense culture it's not that more
people are offended it's that um ten
years ago you had to write a letter i ah
dear BBC I can't be bothered whereas now
you go up you know you're angry do it
and then there's a mob mentality yeah
you know they want they want blood but
what goes around comes around you know
you see these sort of a social justice
warrior on Twitter and they and they
have someone for you know that it's
their particular ism and they have a got
them and they bully them but then what
goes around comes around
because then they get an ism someone
else's ISM wrong and they got and so I
think people go or maybe they won't oh
yeah I made a mistake
maybe that person I bullied made a
mistake so I think I think generally
people now understand that read it first
just read it properly you know just it's
it's such a knee-jerk reaction to be
offended and and sometimes particularly
with jokes people mistake the target of
the joke with the subject of a joke and
they're not necessarily the same it's a
such a knee-jerk reaction to a taboo
subject you know I get it with David
Byrne people say all that that lyric in
that song is a bit off at a bit dodgy oh
yeah
is this a fictional character he's a bit
dodgy he says the wrong things sometimes
what we're not allowed to have bad
people in fiction I'm trying to reflect
the world there are bad people in this
world and so you have to have them in
fiction otherwise you've just
whitewashed everything out and for so
you don't offend anyone
whatever you say someone's going to be
offended so you can't worry about that
just say what you mean say it carefully
and consider it and and you're fine you
know that it's fine if someone's
offended so what just because you're
offended it doesn't mean you're right
just one final question if you don't
mind any thought to bring back some of
the other characters potentially
revisiting maybe Melbourne
oh sorry Andy momentum extras I don't
know um sorry again I'm sorry sorry
sorry
no sorry that was so fascinating about
about today I just I just wanted to ask
this question sure
so do you want to revisit some of the
other characters I mean like extras or
Derek or or is there a point where you
go I've done that I'm going to put that
on the shelf I'm moving on to something
else yeah I mean that that always that
usually wins that I want to do something
new but you know I I said I've never
been about the office and I haven't it's
not the office but I thought it was time
to revisit Brent just for a short while
so Never Say Never I do miss Derek I do
miss extras but um it depends what I'm
doing at the time I mean I've sort of
pushed back
stand up for like six years now and now
I'm starting doing that so I really want
to do after this is all died down my
next thing I want to do another stand up
show because I love it and it's it's a
third of what I do probably stand-up and
um so I'm going to do that so that the
next two years is sort of taken but then
I'll probably do an either a new sitcom
or a new movie or you know a Derek I
don't know